INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM THAT
REPORTING.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
AUTHOR OF THE NUMBER ONE
BEST SELLER HOAX SCHEME TO
CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON AND
FRAME DONALD TRUMP.
THANK YOU ALL.
CONGRESSMAN, LET'S START
WITH YOU.
WE NOW HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE GLENN SIMPSON WON'T
TESTIFY.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WON'T
>> YES.
>> Sean: CONGRESS DOING
THEIR JOB OF OVERSIGHT HAS
BEEN OBSTRUCTED THE ENTIRE
WAY.
YOU WAIT YEARS AND STILL
DON'T GET DOCUMENTS AND THEY
NEVER TOLD THE COURT AND
FISA ABOUT THE POLITICALLOR
JIRNS MEANING CLINTSD
JIRNS MEANING CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR ALL OF.
THIS YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT
THERE.
IS A PATTERN HERE.
WE SHOULD COMPEL GLENN
SIMPSON.
COCK TO CONGRESS AND ASSERT
HIS PRIVILEGE.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO JUST
PHONE IT IN.
HE SHOULD COME THERE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK.
THEY ACTUALLY WANT THE
DEMOCRATS TO WIN.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN, THEY
ARE NEVER GOING TO BE CALLED
IN WANTS FROM OF CONGRESS
AND NEVER GET THE ANSWERS
FOR THE FERN PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE GOAL.
IRS TARGETS CONSERVATIVES
SHE TAKES THE FIFTH.
BRIAN PGA SETS UP CLINTON'S
EMAIL SYSTEM AND EMAIL
SERVER HE TAKES THE FIFTH IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS AND NOW
GLENN SIMPSON THE GUY HIRED
BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WHO
WENT OUT AND HIRED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO PUT
TOGETHER THE FAKE NEWS
DOSSIER, HE HAS TAKEN THE
FIFTH.
I KNOW I'M TIRED OF IT AND I
KNOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE.
>> ORIGINS LITERALLY NEVER
TOLD TO THE FISA COURT.
HE AGAIN HELPED PUT THIS
THING TOGETHER WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
BEYOND THE FRAUD, NOW YOU
HAVE THIS INSTITUTIONALIZED
OBSTRUCTION PEOPLE INVOLVED
WON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
>> WHICH IS THE REASON WHY
CONGRESS SHOULD SUBPOENA ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
THAT SHOULD BE ON THE
AGENDA.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY GLENN
SIMPSON SHOULD BE FOUND IN
CONTEMPT.
IF HE DOESN'T COME AND
DISCUSS THIS BEFORE
CONGRESS.
WE KNOW A CUP PERFORM
THINGS, SEAN BASED ON
REPORTING AND SOURCES.
IT APPEARS GLENN SIMPSON
LIED.
IF HE DID, HE NEEDS TO
EXPLAIN HIMSELF.
THIS IS SOMETHING CONGRESS
SHOULD HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR.
GLENN SIMPSON IS THE ONE
THAT WAS APPARENTLY
SPREADING ALL OF THE STORIES
ABOUT THE ALPHA SERVER.
THE RUSSIAN BANK THAT WAS
COMMUNE CASE WITH TRUMP
TOWER.
AND THEN WE EVENTUALLY
FIGURED OUT BASED ON
EVIDENCE THAT THAT WAS NOT
NOT TRUE.
THE FBI THREW THAT OUT THE
MINUTE THEY STARTED LOOKING
AT IT.
IT DOESN'T STOP GLENN
SIMPSON FROM SPREADING
MALICIOUS LIES THROUGH THE
MEDIA.
WHICH HE WAS DOING EVEN WITH
THE DOES YEA.
I MEAN, OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WE HAVE SAID, THIS SEAN IT
LOOKS LIKE THE HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND DNC
WERE THE ONLY ONES
COLLUDING.
COLLUDING WITH FUSION GPS,
COLLUDING WITH BRITISH
FOREIGN INTENTION ASSET.
A FORMER CHRISTOPHER STEELE
WHO WAS THEN COLLUDING WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD ANY KIND
OF COLLUSION OR
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
RUSSIANS DURINGTH ELECTION.
SO, THE ENTIRE SPECIAL
COUNSEL WAS REALLY BASED ON
FALSE PREMISES.
>> IT WAS BASED ON IT.
BUT NOW IT ALL BEGINS TO
FITS TOGETHER JIM.
LISA PAGE SHED THERE IS TO
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
CO-LOWTION.
>> TRUMP VERY THREAD IS NO
THERE THERE.
NINE MONTHS IN THEY HAD
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THEN THE DOES YEA CREATE THE
IMPRESSION SOMETHING HAD
HAPPENED.
THAT'S HILLARY BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES.
>> SURE.
>> IRONY OF ALL IRONIES AND
WE HAVE GUYS TALKING ABOUT
WEARING A WIRE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND MAYBE TRYING TO INVOKE
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
RECENTLY I DON'T HAVE AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND HE IS
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
ON THE VERY FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE, JEFF SESSIONS BEGAN
HIS RECUSAL FROM THE CASE.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAD A REAL
AND CONFIDENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HE WOULD HAVE
CALLED COMEY INTO HIS OFFICE
AND SAID SHOW ME YOUR
EVIDENCE.
AND THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD DISCOVER THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE.
HE WOULD HAVE SAID SHOW ME
THE EVIDENCE IN THE FISA
WARRANT APPLICATIONS TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
WOULD HAVE DISCOVERED THAT
IT WAS ALL CONJURED BY
HILLARY CLINTON BASTED ON
FABRICATED EVIDENCE.
AND THAT GO AND COMPETENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD HAVE
MARCHED OVER TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND TOLD THE PRESIDENT
YOU MUST FIRE JAMES COMEY
FOR VIOLATING A MYRIAD OF
REVELATIONS AND LAUNCH A
SERIOUS INVESTIGATION IN
FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY INTO
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
HONOR IS SEAN IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE ARE GETTING THERE THOUGH.
BECAUSE NOW YOU VERY, YOU
KNOW, WHICH JAMES BAKER IS
TESTIFYING AND LISA PAGE IS
TELLING SOME TRUTH AND THEY
ALL SEEM TO BE TURNING ON
EACH OTHER.
HERE IS THE QUESTION.
WILL WE EVER GET THE
UNCLASSIFIED REDACTED.
302 INFORMATION, THE FOIZ
WARRANTS AND DO YOU ALL
BELIEVE THIS IS ALL COMING
TO A HEAD AND BACK FIRING
AND PEOPLE WILL PAY THE
PRICE?
JIM JORDAN?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD GET ALL
OF THAT.
INFORMATION.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR IT
MULTIPLE TIMES.
IF YOU REMEMBER A FEW WEEKS
AGO THE PRESIDENT INITIALLY
SAID HE WAS GOING.
TO SAY NOW HE IS RUNNING IT
THROUGH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL GTE IT.
>> YOU HAVE THE 302S WILL
COME BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE.
I CERTAINLY BELIEVE THETA
GANG OF 8 DOCUMENTS AND FISA
COME AFTER THE ELECTION THAT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT LATE.
>> RATS ARE TRAPPED IN A
CAGE AND THEY ARE KNAWING AT
EACH OTHER AND THEY WILL